[Música]
escala en París Braulio Moro
Bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
escala en París un programa semanal de
radio Francis internacional en
colaboración con la televisión Franz 24
en español en la que cada semana damos
la palabra a representantes del mundo de
las ciencias las artes la política los
deportes la cultura y claro Está también
de la sociedad civil hoy nos acompañan
en escala en París dos representantes y
luchadoras de los Derechos Humanos
Carolina de moura que es periodista
brasileña bienvenida Carolina a este
escala en París y Clara a nivel
encargada de la defensoría de actores
económicos en la organización francesa
ccfd tierra solidaria bienvenidas a las
dos un placer tenerlas con nosotros
frecuentemente escuchamos en los medios
hablar de violaciones de Derechos
Humanos por parte de empresas
transnacionales de todos los orígenes
recientemente nos hemos enterado que por
ejemplo en Perú la empresa China
yanacocha la propietaria de la principal
mina de oro en Perú ha bloqueado
literalmente cercado a la población de
del cusco que vive en esa región y más
recientemente en el se presentó también
el caso en Brasil de la empresa vale
propietaria de una Represa de productos
tóxicos que se derrumbó en el lugar de
brumadino provocando 272 muertos todos
estos casos la característica es que
involucran empresas transnacionales y
donde llegar a la justicia cuesta
muchísimo trabajo Carolina de Maura
usted ha representado ha participado en
todo lo que es la lucha por obtener
justicia en el caso del derrumbe de la
empresa de La Represa de brumadino
recuérdenos brevemente qué es lo que
sucedió en el 2019
bien la ruptura de La Represa de
desechos tóxicos de vale es una
consecuencia de un modo de actuar
violento que no respeta a las
comunidades e incluso las leyes
ambientales y fue una tragedia de gran
magnitud como una estructura de 86
metros de altura que en una ola de 30
metros 60 y 20 kilómetros por hora que
cayó en nuestro río el río para opema
que está en el medio de la ciudad de
brumagginho y mató en pocos minutos
272 personas incluso dos mujeres
embarazadas en con sus hijos en sus
vientres y la fuerza de esta ola de
desechos es duro decir pero la verdad
que partió el cuerpo de las personas que
ahí estaban por la fuerza y velocidad de
esta ola Entonces hasta hoy estamos
procurando
las tres personas que no fueran
identificadas
hasta el momento porque sus fragmentos
corpóreos no fueran encontrados de
acuerdo O sea si es una situación a
cuatro años de distancia todavía no hay
justicia si se puede decir así
sí no hay justicia a una lucha larga
la asociación de familiares de víctimas
fatales todos los días 25 que fue el día
de la tragedia hacen una actividad de
memoria en la entrada de la ciudad por
encuentro de las de todas las víctimas
justicia y memoria hay procesos que que
caminan pero el sistema judicial no no
no no da contra de hacer la justicia que
necesitamos
Clara a libertad a usted le ha tocado
participar Precisamente en la defensoría
de varias comunidades referidas a
empresas francesas notablemente en el
2017 Francia aprobó una ley pionera en
su tipo que es la ley de deber de
vigilancia explíquenos brevemente que se
esta ley y denos algún ejemplo de lo que
se ha logrado cinco años después de esta
aprobación de esta ley sí es una ley
pionera porque fue la primera del mundo
una ley que quiere regular las
actividades de las empresas en cuanto a
sus impactos en derechos humanos y e
impactos en el medio ambiente lo que
quiere esta ley
se puede resumir en dos Pilares primero
la prevención es decir que todas las
empresas francesas grandes estamos
hablando de empresas con más de cinco
mil empleados en Francia o 10.000
empleados en el mundo pues esas empresas
tienen que publicar un plan de
vigilancia Y en este plan tienen que
identificar los riesgos que sus
actividades puedan producir en cualquier
país en el que estén desarrollando sus
actividades también un Pilar muy
importante y Carolina lo ha hablado es
el acceso a la justicia y esta ley
permite a personas víctimas a los
familiares a cualquier personas persona
afectada pues ir a justicia ir a juicio
para obtener justicia y para obtener
reparación si hubo un prejuicio Déjenme
decirles que tanto Carolina como Clara
participan en un documental que ha
salido en octubre del año pasado que se
llama la ilusión de la abundancia que ha
ganado varios premios ha participado en
distintos festivales y que esperamos
Próximamente ustedes lo puedan consultar
ver En plataformas o incluso en varios
festivales en sus respectivos países
Carolina en octubre pasado usted viajó a
Bruselas precisamente se presentó ante
parlamento europeo sabemos que en un
primer tiempo los representantes de la
empresa vale que es una de las grandes
empresas brasileñas que es la tercera
más importante del Brasil fueron en un
primer momento detenidos Me gustaría
saber cuál es la situación actualmente
pero sobre todo Me gustaría saber qué
pasó con la empresa que dio el
certificado de que La Represa estaba en
buen estado Que es una empresa alemana y
que se llama Ni más ni menos que
sí
como la tragedia 2019 no fue la segunda
la segunda gran de tragedia que vivimos
porque en 2015 pasó otra tragedia con
una Represa de Mariana de San marco en
Mariana Entonces como la institución las
instituciones de Justicia fueran rápidas
en hacer la investigación luego después
de del crimen de 2019 fue una buena
investigación ellos capturaron
computadoras con ellos electrónicos
entre la empresa Vale y La certificadora
alemana Y eso está muy bueno porque por
lo menos un poco de la verdad tenemos
información Gracias a esta investigación
ha hecho por la fiscalía pública de
minas gerais Y entonces junto con cinco
mujeres familiares de víctimas fatales
abrimos una demanda penal en contra
Munich y hasta el momento está en fase
de investigación ojalá se concluya y los
responsables También acá en Alemania en
Europa sean responsabilizados en Brasil
estamos en un trabajo como cotidiano día
a día en busca de Justicia acompañando
los procesos penales y hasta el momento
tenemos
de ese seis personas acusadas
11 de vale es 5 de tupsut Brasil pero
eso está en camino llevamos como todos
este hasta hoy discutiendo la la
jurisdicción competente para juzgarlos y
están
Están
el homicidio doloso con intencionalidad
de matar el crimen ambientales la
acusación la acusación es de homicidio
doloso 272 veces
y crímenes ambientales se puede decir
que la justicia tarda tiempo en llegar y
tanto en los casos como el que vemos de
brumadino hemos visto casos y lo vamos a
citar de empresas como en yanacocha esta
empresa de China hemos visto otros casos
a nivel internacional hay una cosa que
es que cuando las víctimas hablan de el
acceso a la justicia ambiental es
correcto Este término Sí bueno es
correcto y es algo que se ve más y más
en cualquier país y por ejemplo Incluso
en Francia con el caso del siglo la que
es una búsqueda de la justicia ambiental
pero yo creo que más que justicia
ambiental el término más importante es
justicia porque las comunidades los
pueblos indígenas los jóvenes están
buscando por una justicia holística una
justicia económica una justicia social
porque ellos cuando luchan para sus
tierras también luchan para todas y
todos luchan para la madre tierra y no
hay una desconexión entre lo ambiental y
los Derechos Humanos todo está vinculado
y todo tiene su importancia en en esta
lucha hay algo que ustedes habrán dado
cuenta que es que cada vez que hay una
violación un accidente cuando involucra
alguna empresa transnacional siempre se
hace referencia a un punto que viene de
manera recurrente y es la
autorregulación de la gestión de las
empresas transnacionales de las grandes
empresas decir que ellas mismas evalúan
el factor de riesgo frente a esta
situación Carolina ha surgido desde el
2015 una iniciativa a nivel
internacional
impulsada por organizaciones en todo el
mundo europeas asiáticas de América
Latina Estados Unidos etcétera que
plantea la necesidad de aprobar un
tratado internacional vinculante es
decir obligatorio que regule el
funcionamiento de las empresas
transnacionales este tratado entiendo yo
empezó a discutirse en el 2015 en el
consejo de derechos humanos de la
Organización de las Naciones Unidas qué
cambiaría la aprobación de este tratado
para las comunidades que se ven
afectadas por este tipo de situaciones
creemos que el tratado vinculante es muy
importante es aprendimos en años de
lucha que definitivamente no es posible
confiar en la buena fe de las empresas
en medidas de alto regulación Entonces
es muy importante tener Esta esta este
marco de vinculante para empresas hay
tratados vinculantes que podemos acceder
hablar con gobiernos como denunciar
gobiernos pero directamente empresas
aún no hay Y eso es un camino muy
importante y ojalá rápido logremos que
este tratado sea aprobado claro Hay una
relación entre ese tratado vinculante y
la ley de deber de vigilancia que se ha
aprobado en Francia Sí bueno la ley
inspiró muchos países inspiró a Alemania
Países Bajos pero ya ahora a España y
también hay primeras
conversaciones en Brasil inspiró también
a la Unión Europea porque ahora hay una
directiva europea sobre sobre este este
tema y entonces inspiró también las
Naciones Unidas y sobre todo es
importante tener varios instrumentos de
diferentes niveles porque hoy en día
cualquier producto cualquier servicio
implica a varios países y no solamente
hay una empresa francesa por lo tanto
para tener la responsabilidad de todas y
todos es necesario tener un instrumento
que multilateral que embarca a todos los
países del mundo es lo que se intenta
hacer con esas negociaciones del tratado
vinculante a este propósito sabemos que
hay varias organizaciones empresas
transnacionales francesas para ser más
preciso que están denunciadas por
organizaciones como la suya estamos
hablando del caso de total en uganda ha
habido el caso de bonafonte en el caso
de México por la explotación de del agua
el caso de danon por la falta de
reconversión de los productos plásticos
esperan que esto tenga resultados
rápidamente en base a esa ley de deber
de vigilancia sí lo esperamos y
necesitamos primera jurisprudencia
digamos para para entender mejor esta
ley y para para que las empresas también
entiendan que hay que aplicar la ley y
que no solamente se trata de un de un
ejercicio de chequeo no de decir Bueno
yo he publicado mi plan de vigilancia
estoy bien no un poco como lo de la
certificación yo tengo certificado mi
mina o no hay que entender que estamos
cambiando de paradigma durante muchos
años las empresas han pensado en riesgos
para ellos y lo que queremos con el
deber de vigilancia es hacerlos entender
que hay que pensar en los riesgos para
el planeta y el riesgo es para los
pueblos es un cambio de paradigma y por
lo tanto necesitamos la justicia para
apoyar Este cambio Pues estamos llegando
ya al final de esta escala en París no
me queda sino agradecer a Carolina de
moura periodista brasileña su presencia
aquí en esta escala Gracias por habernos
acompañado y aclara a ver representante
también de la Organización
ccfd de Francia su presencia en nuestros
estudios Muchísimas gracias a los dos a
ustedes les damos una próxima cita aquí
la semana entrante en otra escala en
París
[Música]